coronavirus pandemic has left local
blood banks in desperate need
in fact only three out of every 100
Americans actually donates blood and
that's just not enough to keep up with
demand yeah especially right now our
Bianca Holman is live with the urgent
need here in Las Vegas beyond good
morning to you hey good morning yes the
Red Cross definitely needs our help
there is actually a blood drive
scheduled today here at Centennial Hills
library thankfully it's booked up so but
there are several more blood drives that
are open available for you to make an
appointment and they definitely need our
help so blood drives they are typically
at high schools and colleges during this
time but they've been on hold for months
those typically account for 20% of
donations during the year that combined
with the corona virus is keeping some
regular donors away has left Southern
Nevada in critical need the Red Cross
says donations are safe the corona virus
cannot be transmitted through blood and
the organization is taking precautions
to protect its staff and donors Hospital
demand have gone up about 30 percent
from you know hospitals may now resumed
patient treatments and surgeries that
were temporarily paused at the start of
the pandemic they have now resumed so we
are facing that increase so today's
Drive at Centennial Hills library is
booked but there are two more dates at
Fashion Show Mall July 15th and July
16th you can see those details here on
your screen and you can find other
drives at Red Cross Blood dot org to
sign up for an appointment there now to
bonuses for donors all donations will be
tested for the Cova 19 antibody tests
and that's to see if you have been
exposed to the virus and then also you
will be entered into a national drawing
for a wonder woman's movie props package
so to bonuses if you come out to donate
over the next couple of weeks
reporting live since some content
reporting live from Centennial Hills
library Bianca Holman 8 News now